lots of time to spare wait I'm not live
they say new sometimes like a 15-second
delay Here I am okay I'm gonna play
chess let's play a staffer gambit or
petrov knight c6 pre-move for knights
Halloween gambit reverse let's have some
fun
oh he gives back the piece so boring
Bishop e6 looks decent
maybe 94 coming my d4 Queen there let's
develop whoa
now 94 and then I can what does this
position takes takes you seven takes a
one I'm so confused
King takes defending my rook it's a
miracle let's bring the knight back I
don't deserve to win this but I'm cape
on cloud style I'm pinned let's escape
f5 always playoff v or f6 Queen e5 is
gonna be uncomfortable maybe Seif no not
c5 yeah what is this position I have to
defend somehow but it also attacks from
how oh let's check and distract the
Queen from attacking g7 and then it's
gonna be equal material no I'm down upon
but it could be worse let's do that boo
Bishop a3 will or that will kill me
let's do this
oh this is so bad I resign how does a
terrible start of such a confusing
position too
wait there's people in the chats znation
Ches I have the chats open on both
monitors like extra monitor for extra
chat okay
I'll bathe there's very little time to
look at the chats especially after your
losing the first game see six passive
let's play this a four okay so I
essentially have an extra tempo multiple
extra ten ph5 coming let's defend the
pawn first blocks wasted so much time
but how do i punish him mmm
a five I can't complain can read the
chat greetings everyone just add blue
where'd you come from
okay I'm sacking because why not
assignation Ches lolly it's I read the
chat and play at the same time the
screen is stretched really it's a long
[Music]
monitor but is that is it actually like
that bad
I wonder if the proportions are off
well what did i do sign in No okay that
was weird uh II for where are my
proportions also Grand Prix time ooh
Center for trick unexpected let's play
this move mmm forking everything that's
not a bad move okay I have night
domination now I have to go back okay
let's trade stuff
oh I hung a piece if he takes g4 okay
now I'm giving piece odds
oh so unfortunate I thankfully my pawns
are smiling let's play a six oh you saw
it
okay I have to defend this guy King III
coming I'm down on time yeah well
trained I'll play rook before and maybe
win this guy he's gonna win this guy
let's take ooh okay that was tricky but
I'll have a past
a pawn it's my only hope it's gotta run
faster faster wait what they were there
there Oh Bishop d4 so I can take your
first and then rook c4 defending bring
my king in I have two connected passes
he has one connected passer now it's a
race who is he gonna trade
okay I think trading one for black now
it's a time scramble and a pawn race
fight till the death okay I think I'm
just winning this he can't break through
quickly enough
hey sevens coming and he's flying okay
well the game you check my twitch mmm
that's a little bit actually it's okay I
think it's just an optical illusion that
it's stretched let's play a London this
guy looks strong hey we have a sub Saren
Elio what subs Dumas my other monitor is
like off oh can I take my Bishop d2
solid h3 preventing Bishop g4 maybe this
move the Queen here I I can't play g4
maybe I'll play Queen e2 tricky tricky
threatening g4 oh no not yet but soon
it's bits it's not an optical illusion
you sure
is it really broken oh no okay I'll fix
it soon but let me finish this game
wasting a lot of time here so much
attack but also so much defense
I take c2 looks okay
like Bishop does that move
that's a really strong move what a move
hoping he gets confused just take g2
played the right move let's move back up
to break down his pawn chain and a5 move
I hung a bishop but he didn't take it
I'm down on time let's take that no no
he flagged me three moves are tough I
fix this doesn't look stretched five
hundred bits yeah maybe the resolution
doesn't match the screen is this 94 okay
I'll fix it after I maybe win the
tournament I'm not doing Mac rates I'm
gonna go for the kill play slightly
slightly dubiously because that's how
you win quickly also thanks for the bits
sarony leo 500 bits
okay now I'm winning I think Bishop
takes candiates
no more checks threatening different
types of mates maybe wait not yet maybe
takes here first and then Queen g3 is
Gigi if takes I'm eights
if not I'm eight
I was gonna remove takes t5 but he could
play Bishop t5 and takes takes gets
messy okay
GG that was fun uh 18th place six points
who's leaning dark phoenix is leading
okay let's play let's play normal chess
more bits from love HS stretch screen
its is fine no worries okay good to hear
yeah I'll fix it after this tournament
I'm still learning this new setup and
layout and I'm using stream labs OBS
which is different from normal OBS it's
a whole learning curve let's make things
messy I'm just losing a pollen or two
pawns hey macro set with Assad at two
months nice good to see you Matt but
White has double ponds he just won
another one I have a spy check and rook
e8 a double up rook d7 I played this
move superfluous Knights I want to go
for this this and something maybe each
mmm let's do this first attacking this
and maybe threatening this yeah and he
is he meeting me no he's not meeting me
I always have neither fate necessary
yeah he was trying to be tricky cuz I
could have taken the bishop first but
I'll still win the bishop could pre move
it and then let's not get mated
ooh white might be promoting but also
might be flagging oh I got for it
don't flag me or don't be me okay this
is actually winning endgame okay Gigi is
just 99% tactics it depends on the type
of chess if it's bullet it's 99% moving
quickly and not blundering if it's like
a strong player is it's like 99% opening
preparation mainly like the World
Championship match anyway let's play
let's play and play a London she's a
little rated let's try not to use any
time okay I have the bishop pair sacking
upon sort of unintentionally c4 why not
okay dark sprays are gonna be very juicy
before coming mmm whoa f4 why not
I wouldn't connect 4 E 5 pre move now
he's just confused and I went on time
hey I'm winning a queen okay
it turns good really quickly and now I
have a gun on the F file
let's sack them Bishop and then I'll
take or that so much pressure on f7 okay
this is guaranteed to be double
checkmate GG okay another game let's
preserve cuz working makes things more
interesting sometimes this is a fun line
I think do that sacking the Jeep on but
not really but maybe Bishop f4 I forgot
like wizards to move a bit quicker
oh I hung a queen no he saw it okay so
now Queen odds and time odds but I have
a slightly closed position I have more
rating points he's retreating it's a
good sign it's maneuver the knight try
and confuse him we went threatening a
fork he saw it's I'm pinning he saw that
let's play this attack the pinned upon
turn in the fork again please don't see
it he didn't see it when the Queen back
pawn storm time hot storm more like a
pawn blunder but it's okay
what plunder he didn't take it wait I'm
down a piece
am i down the piece time to flag him who
I hung a rook he just doesn't take it
just take it you know you want to my
Brooke was hanging for like the whole
game and we were too too slow I was too
slow to move it he was too slow to take
it I was down the Queen there for most
of the game that's what you call quality
chess
I don't beserk this guy cuz he beat me
already I forgot how he beat me
oh yeah the four Knights okay last time
I played Halloween this time I'll play
solidly aged six new over the night hey
another sub resub a 2306 Roy thanks for
everything
it's jennasmith tacking stuff Castle
King safety first retreats I want to
play Knight c4 someday it's never gonna
happen
v8 my Knights so bad his Knights so good
okay I'm gonna close things down and I
want to bring the knight to e6
Brooke I'm d8 mm I can take well I could
have taken last move while I'm winning a
piece because pins
I'll stick with Knights and check Nate's
house nice rogue h1 was the worst
possible move in that position thanks
for all the new people and people in the
chat I'm probably just ignoring I'm in
first place in the tournament because I
won a lot of games in a row either rocky
starts also things
Dola bill bill thank for subbing let's
play a dubious can bit go after the
nevermind
it's yf6 confuse him okay now I'm just
down upon limited compensation now I win
the pawn back this is actually a really
nice position
because 9f2 will come eventually or my
rook will come to that file mmm let's
start with that take upon my pieces are
just so happy let's do this I want to go
in for the kill
he can't stop 93 unless he like
physically softs me let's do this and
check I mean I'm just winging a piece
mmm
oh the bishops hanging - and I'm
threatening this it's like Christmas so
much free stuff okay I'm up to pieces
let's go for the meeting attack
I missed a fork probably not the best
technique here but at least I'm not
paying anything yet I'll post on b5 mmm
free rook okay
GG yeah there is a big time advantage
there - also rod twinks took over my
first spots but I took over his reigning
2503 okay 26 points we're both on
streaks this is a guy I lost to first
round I beat the next round let's place
the ceiling this time time manav move
this line B 5 I think is a trendy move
and then that's interesting let's play
this and this
and that d5 coming d5 I guess kind of
works maybe it doesn't work probably
dropping upon yeah mmm stop taking stuff
let's take their how much am i down I
have a ruck for a - - could be worse
should've played b5 there I still have
b5 ideas
oh I lost a piece b5 doesn't even work
as a knight takes b5 have to start with
that oh this is so bad still some ideas
my gosh h5 ok now I just have to hope
and pray taxi - mm let's take it hanging
f7 it's not trade Queens yet I won't
play h3 and Queen d2 mates
please don't see Queen g2 please please
please all he saw it
let's do this move and take the rook
wait this is really bad Queen d3 oops
that was a terrible finished
yeah he just outplayed me that game I
was trying to make tactics work but they
just didn't work now I need rod twinks
to lose or if he wins it'll be more
challenging with two zerk and let's play
against a Sicilian close Sicilian style
h3g for can only use three seconds for
the first twelve moons
too bad let's play I five sacking maybe
upon this looks really fun now cuz I
have a pawn storm attack coming he
doesn't really have an umbrella and
files are about to open starting to take
let's take a free pawn by g6 takes takes
takes takes let's do this all night
you're a g6 bishop there bring the rook
in mmm that's annoying I defend
everything I can't defend everything
it's do this huh wait this was bad now
I'm down on time done a lot of time down
way too much time too much
second-guessing dirty move no I was
close to winning that it's Sony moves
with zero seconds left
oh that's so unfortunate let's play a
London okay rod twinks has 30 I still
have 26 just to slow their let's play d5
this is gonna be sharp
let's play h4 kind of liking the
position h5 coming I'd see one to be
safe
controlling c4 it's interesting let's
take and play h5 Queen g5 I just have
night b3 if necessary
this is still very sharp like I don't
know what's going on but as long as he's
thinking and happy f5 is now a square to
use d4 let's take Bishop d3 okay now
it's just a mess free Brooke that's kind
it was very kind
let's do this there's my stuff maybe I
can trade nights bring another night to
d4 queen h2o that's tricky it's defend
defend the pawn I think this is all okay
it's still kind of annoying boo free
Queen
five seconds left be as one second left
okay Gigi I'm in third place 28 points
rod twinks losses streak Smurf has
leapfrogged me winning all his games
okay now I'm playing this guy the
berserk
you took rack up some points Sicilian oh
this guy again
okay let's scream move quicker this time
[Music]
same sort of pawn storm h4 h5 coming
whoa stuff is happening okay I'm up at
night I want to bring the Knight to g4
I'm happy to take to Bishop but doesn't
belong on h3
I'm just up a happy piece but the
positions closed could take a while to
win this can't close it down completely
start pre moving yeah these close
positions are fun because you have
unlimited time and yeah he was hoping I
would pre move their pre move h7 can
take that bring the route t1 put the
rook on e5 it's just full domination
triple up on the file let's go after the
D pawn whoa I was nice
okay Gigi oh I won that time that game
okay 31 points Smurf has too many points
let's be them we have a veresov slide
okay he knows kind of what he's doing
what is e six should be just six wins
some deep theory here I'm not sure what
this is 95 czar nice moves though maybe
I can start with this do you want a
Castle queenside eventually I let's move
back okay nice time and bandage play
Queenie 7 @ h5 I can play Knight g4
still Knight g4 takes play this pairing
something simple maybe 95 back let's do
this first
mm takes it's kind of annoying
I'll lose a pawn to look at counter play
that's the sky defend this guy prepare
this check it's moving the corner I was
good move
everything's still kind of defending
attacking that guy defending this guy
threatening the square mm-hmm let's do
this first attacking that guy there
should be 3 invade a6 loot for the King
attack the knight maybe let's take the
Knights and take that check there are
tactics here a4 defend attack have three
coming mmm that move does that win I
think that wins yes
easy win while the finish look at that
slow-motion replay ban promotion tactics
okay back to tournaments I am still in
third place but I've shortened the gap
Smurf losses
actually that was Smurfs first loss so
life is better playing the styles buzzer
again let's play london this time i want
to cream of that okay there we go okay
some hippo it's likeif I've sac upon not
really but maybe
yeah I'm sacking upon but he's not
taking it now I'm having a nice square C
4 comes 96 will come it's a night
trapped
it was almost trapped it always play
Bishop b1 let's move before coming just
pre move it I should be for next I don't
care about pawns I care about open files
and sometimes pawns turning natan 1 now
threatening bishop t3 always retreat
Bishop a5 check maybe I for coming
oooh for I sac but maybe it's ok he's 7
I just sacked a pawn for no reason he's
not taking it let's do that now both
rooks are tied to each other
where's my old my Queens hanging let's
trade to this i buzzard I forgot his
Ertz I'm winning a piece what is he
doing he's trying to slow me down free
material everywhere
Oh easy win BAM
so strong okay dr. tournament you almost
flagged me until I made it in first
place 40 points feel the hype floor
experts
okay let's cover him with carpets let's
play this move and it's so complicated
already nice time advantage probably
should've Izzard this game but that's
okay
tacking upon winning upon attacking
another pond let's check take it Bishop
no I'll probably just complete
development win a pawn defend a7 win
another pond win another pond bring
another pond defend I have a past a pond
let's push it I think this is defended
if I can count its defend from a
distance
I'll check from a distance Queen a one
coming and wide open positions like
those Queens can be very resourceful
also I'm up a lot of time can do
anything really it's just starts by
checking ok good game too fast
you actually played decently but he was
just a little too slow mmm playing a
smurf again ok so he plays this veresov
same line
okay I'm fine going into this seems very
fine for black the same exact opening
maybe Queen h4 check I didn't play this
move last time forget what happened last
time
he can't Castle queenside don't think he
wants to Castle King ahead let's move
back to g7 this is actually very similar
to last time can I take it was like
weenie 794 so so similar maybe e5 95
let's take that tack okay I can create
an outpost on f4 positional chess defend
this pawn b5 and now Knight f4 coming we
can trade rooks maybe this move I want
to take over the D file well I got
forked but he might get made it if he
takes my Queen was this position this is
still okay for black I guess let's take
that threatening Maiden
oh no that's not means it's close to
mate I have a good knife first sort of
good Bishop let's activate the King I'm
down a lot of time but he can't break
through I don't think I have to break
through this way walk around there we go
no life lagged in a winning made into
position
oh he's too fast
I'm too slow I was strong but I was too
slow
alright don't tilt deep breath
it was 96 let's take that III check tak
the bishop let's take the ax okay I have
the bishop pair Black has summer ponds
black has three Center ponds now two
Center ponds
I'm just winning material oh you play
King eh eh I can see it let's play that
move when a seven maybe I don't think
I'm getting needed can take be 7 next
checking the rook and the knight can't
take the knight right away but f4 is
coming now both these pieces are hanging
let's take this first and now I'm just
upper Brook defend that let's take this
defend oh i blundered i'm still up on
time kind of was careless I'm trading
Queens oh it's nice oh my gosh I'm
really miss playing this thankfully I'm
still winning like somehow there we go
okay hey I'm back in first place somehow
but Smurf and Rudd twinks have a streak
and they're very close behind this is
tricky rod twinks again um I forgot what
we played the first time okay play this
line
this can't be bad for black think you
really messed up somewhere just up up on
its castle so you know this move
attack the night hoping files III ideas
through this fianchetto very strong
fianchetto 94 coming mmm Bishop here
almost drops of rook yeah the Knights
pins of the pawn g5 is annoying though
okay so we trade a little bit I still
have my pawn attacking these guys let's
take that do this pocket h5 they see 695
ideas Oh free pond let's push I fork
ideas and that's the guy like this so we
just trade mm-hmm let's do this stopping
rookie 7 prevent fishin t6 we can trade
sure screening stuff
this is endgame this doesn't look great
but I'm up on time it's gonna be a time
scramble
oh no he's promoting please flag just
fine
hey stalemate okay
can't complain I'm still lost there yeah
it should have been a win I'm in third
place this was actually a really close
like turned into 18 minutes left almost
out of t playing floor expert again okay
to show him who's boss
this line again should be to each 524
okay this is gonna be fun
get ready for it Queenie five threats
this is very hard to defend I think
better be hard to defend wait how does
he stop mate I don't think he can oh
maybe takes with Bishop on g4 yeah but
it's still so strong like take stuff
take more stuff I should cheat for if g3
mm-hmm um I mean there's so many great
looking options where some mates assume
this is working castling queenside okay
I mean White's gonna flag somehow some
way exactly Queen on e4 okay not to turn
mints so I got the buzzer King points
I'm tied for first I'm a completely
ignoring the chat
I need a stalemate you know that's
correct the fucsia let's play in London
because I have a London emote okay we
have a main line this time I don't mind
this it's like a stone wall with the bad
bishop but it couldn't be a good Bishop
if it tries Knight g4 rule let's move
back ideas of pushing pawns and lifting
rooks and may be sacking pawns
let's take here its position slightly
questionable like rook h5
I don't know what's going on let's take
that do this takes takes he's winning
the rock he wins h2o he wins that stuff
too that's annoying maybe when he six
drop ah to do that okay so I have an
outpost on e5 let's do this and defend
from behind oh no wasn't my pawn so it's
really risky I don't think I'm getting
needed yet up a lot of time to winning
this pawn nope I got mated how did I get
made in so one thing I was not supposed
to allow to have happen okay I'm still
within three points of the lead but
every game matters at this point playing
some earth again this game especially
matters let's do the sign okay - keep
the time advantage f3 maybe for somebody
like today that's a good move maybe I
can wait no that's a terrible move GG yo
okay three three or no third place still
got two points 52 points a cash money
and cash money and that name sounds
familiar
[Music]
wait I just blunder kind of let's do
this move at least I'm developing can
take something you choose kind of weak
let's not trade Queens prevent light
from casting naggy for coming someday I
could sack - this looks so pleasant
Bishop t3 such a nice orifice rookie 7
it's take here and then maybe this move
just get everyone into play wow that's
interesting
takes cuts trade wanna win that guy each
five down on time though this is not a
great position but it is a position
let's play Queen e2 tacking stuff
threatening Queen e1 threatening c4 he's
playing well here go back defend c4 now
ah I'm so slow I'm so slow good game
though played well just now we're
catching up
I still have 52 points I'm still within
a few points of the lead but I can't be
losing so many games like that it's
unacceptable
h5 coming ok
this will be fun this moves fun - King
there wait Bishop trap GG yo you gonna
play it on oh he is
but the position ok very nice need those
quick wins still within two points rod
twinks ok he's leading what's going on
here I'm not the pawn let's play this
move it's a good move let's do that move
it stake ok can't complain
ooh now I can complain oh this is really
bad I even deal with this I have to sack
apiece
do you seek my night please okay I'm
down a piece life is pretty bad
mm-hmm
that's worse - but I have a night
my time situation - it's so unfortunate
okay seventh ranked Queen d2 I guess g2
when a7 will maybe defend so rook to e8
ideas
it's so sad
no I'm just praying for cellmate like
that one game just still maybe oh man
the ladder keeps coming no what a brutal
final position I was so sad I'm in third
place
rod twinks has oh that was not the
person to lose to so I have to like
berserk to like have any hope I need to
play someone that's miserable it was
miserable
this guy's bizarre Cobra okay let's play
aggressively reverse Grand Prix take
there at 5-4 f4 okay this is gonna be a
fun attack already have amazing ideas on
each to eventually like all the pieces
are participating they work on a and
will eventually participate if needed
can take here takes like where's the
finish takes here there we go may next
move King there and it's meats okay
needed that back to tournaments those
nice three points of the lead rod twinks
has all these twos like six twos in a
row
I need to get threes berserk and
probably not London again let's play the
sign play the fancy line g6 is playable
I think that's playable I can take 27
that's Castle queenside I just want to
be solid that's why not by day five oh
this is looking good oh I own the night
but I'm threatening Bishop f5 or the
trap accidental trap take with check
let's move let's play this move open the
file
defend against e6 h6 attack tonight
now fork these guys b6 defend let's
retreat and then take attack again then
take take here let's play
attack these guys okay attacking more
guys he's running out of guys for me to
attack
okay chichi I didn't buzz Erick but I
have won points I'm on a streak now a
win a non buzzer King one win will get
me four points which should catapult me
because he just keeps getting twos and
the top guys are playing that's what I
need okay
so I'm not gonna be zerk just gonna go
for a smooth hopefully quick win it's
taking this time I like that okay this
is a fun line again guys should
recognize this from the other game
meeting ideas here each file might open
that's a good move any fives usually the
best move Queen d4 it's still very
tricky though because this is attacked
let's take here I'm down a piece but I
can bullet this is hard for for a white
still because he's kind of stuck I just
want to meet mm actually let's just go
here go here and then now I'm just
mating no way to stop Queen h2 or Queen
h1 from down two pieces you can't stop
me so beautiful I'm back in first place
I have 63 points and I have a streak and
I'm playing a cash money again let's
beat him with his own opening let's play
why so slow let's play this line let's
do this move
[Music]
ah ooh this isn't me fun attack such a
fun attack yeah this is so difficult
this nights out of play now we're gonna
take and play 95 and have some fun
so much fun so much fun
maybe this move mmm it's way Queenie six
I wasn't sure what to do that actually
there is so many good looking options
just have to play some moves it's still
a great position I hear is coming let's
invade with a rook B 3 C 4 coming let's
still do that ok I'm playing a little
bit risky I still like the position so I
see 5 what does that move let's do that
it's not working opposition always got
opposition Queen e1 is either made
threats where's my mate like what is
this okay Brooke hey fives Me's or
that's a pre Queen
there we go back to tournaments
extending my lead there's two minutes
left
I might actually win this tournament it
could be a miracle I don't know what I'm
missing in the chat but thanks guys for
watching I'm like almost out of tea
probably only time for one more game
that's dessert let's finish strong Oh
pre-move knight c6 I've lost upon
already but it's like and it's because I
have strong pawns and this Knights a a
soccer ball is kicking it around now
this is actually playable for black but
it's also playable for white I think
what is this
the center is kind of crumbling I ever
work on d1 let's play that now I have a
pawn on d6 don't play b6 ah positional
move okay let's attack the rut get the
ifile
triple up double threat mmm free rook
always play king h1 work see one's a
threat and this game should finish
before the tournament ends especially
now
Hey
so Smurf needs to like buzzer Quinn oh
he's actually pretty close I assumed he
would have dessert oh he didn't beserk
so I'm pretty sure I'll win but we'll
watch this game no the tournament's over
hey the music confetti first place it's
been a while since I've won high five
that's a lot of high five okay and some
hand yeah okay okay I need a break
I was a lot of bullet Ches I start to
talk and play bullets yeah what'd I miss
you do your modding abilities you time
oh it happens probably they deserved it
okay thanks guys for watching um yeah I
mean having mods is better than having
no mods challenge mark asked him into a
classical game but I'm tired I'm so
tired
maybe I just raid mark a sermon and
that'll be that yeah I think I missed
most of the chats like it couldn't only
scroll up so far but it seems like you
guys are having some nice conversations
funky selves yes so yeah my brain needs
rest so I'm getting zero challenges nice
I'm tired it's been a long day oh now
I'm getting a challenge little Plotkin
whole clock ins way too underrated he
used to be like 2700
what's this hi and he uses a touchpad
it's just not fair well it raining
highest rating was 28 32 yeah I don't
want to like be farmed so um did I miss
stuff oh I missed a sub whoa
I created a new chest and salt buzzer
Keable oh yeah I mean there's a certain
like group of players who are like very
visible but I'm sorry if I insulted
anyone um I missed your sub I don't know
if stream labs is working with
notifications but yeah and I have to fix
the layout too there's some weird stuff
with a ratio and scenes it's so nice to
have a mouse like this Mouse it's like
the chess piranha it's so fast okay so
for the YouTube people watching in the
future if I put this on youtube
smash the subscribe button leave a
comment below tell me something
interesting in the comments like I don't
know what's your favorite thing to do
apart from watching me and and yeah I'll
see you in the future